.
SOME WOMEN WILL HAVE TO DRIVE
FOR HOURS TO REACH THE NEXT
STATE LINE IF THEY GET A LEGAL
ABORTION, THAT IS IF SHE CAN
AFFORD IT.
GLORIA ALLRED REPRESENTED NORMA
McCORBY WHO IS JANE ROE.
GLORIA, WHAT WAS YOUR REACTION
WHEN YOU HEARD THIS LAW IN TEXAS
WOULD BE ALLOWED STAY ON THE
BOOKS?
WHAT DID YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I IMMEDIATELY THOUGHT WE HAVE
TO FIGHT AGAINST THIS.
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING WE CAN
LEGALLY, POLITICALLY,
EMOTIONALLY.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE STREETS AS
WELL, PUT OUR BODIES ON THE LINE
TO SUPPORT THE WOMEN OF TEXAS
WHO ARE GOING TO BE HURT BY
THIS, JIM.
AND THEY ARE GOING TO BE HURT.
AND IT'S NOT JUST BECAUSE
THERE'S A BAN ON ABORTION,
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REALLY A BAN ON
ABORTION.
BECAUSE WOMEN ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO GET ABORTIONS IN
TEXAS, BUT THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO GO TO THOSE WHO ARE NOT
LICENSED DOCTORS OR HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS, THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO IT IN SECRET, THEY'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO POSSIBLY BE IN
A BATHTUB AND ALMOST HEMORRHAGE
TO DEATH FROM THE ABORTION
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE
PROVIDED BY PEOPLE WHO ARE ONLY
GOING TO DO IT FOR PROFIT AND
DON'T KNOW HOW TIED LEGAL
ABORTION.
WOMEN WILL DIE.
POOR WOMEN, MINORITY WOMEN,
RURAL WOMEN WHO MAYBE DON'T KNOW
THAT SOME COMPANIES WILL PROVIDE
FUNDS FOR THEM TO TRAVEL TO
OTHER STATES TO GET ABORTIONS.
OR MAYBE THEY CAN'T LEAVE THEIR
HOME.
MAYBE THEY'VE GOT CHILDREN THERE
TO TAKE CARE OF.
I KNOW FROM PERSONAL EXPERIENCE
WHAT IT'S LIKE TO LIVE IN THE
UNITED STATES AND TO HAVE TO GET
AN ABORTION WHEN IT WAS ILLEGAL
TO DO SO, BECAUSE THAT HAPPENED
TO ME BEFORE ROE V. WADE IN 1973
WHEN I WAS IN MY 20s.
AND I ENDED UP GOING ON A DATE
WITH A PHYSICIAN WHO WAS A
MEXICAN DOCTOR, AND ON THE DATE,
HE SAID FIRST HE NEEDED TO MAKE
SOME HOUSE CALLS, WHICH WE DID,
AND THEN HE SAID HE HAD A
PATIENT IN A MOTEL, HE NEEDED TO
SEE THAT PERSON, AND WE WENT
TOGETHER, AND WE WENT INTO THE
ROOM.
THERE WAS NO PATIENT.
HE PULLED A GUN AND RAPED ME.
ULTIMATELY I BECAME PREGNANT.
I RETURNED TO CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT WAS A CRIME IN 1966 BECAUSE
THAT'S BEFORE ROE V. WADE TO GET
AN ABORTION.
AND SO ULTIMATELY I DID GET THAT
ABORTION FROM AN UNLICENSED
HEALTH CARE PROVIDER, SOMEBODY
WHO JUST DID IT FOR THE MONEY.
I GOT A 106-DEGREE FEVER AS A
RESULT.
I CALLED HIM, HE SAID HE
COULDN'T HELP WITH THE
AFTERMATH.
I WAS TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL
WHERE THEY HAD A SPECIAL WARD
JUST FOR WOMEN WHO WERE DYING
FROM ILLEGAL ABORTIONS, AND A
NURSE SAID TO ME, EVEN THOUGH
SHE DIDN'T I KNOW I WAS RAPED,
BUT SHE SAID, THIS WILL TEACH
YOU A LESSON.
OF COURSE, I DID LEARN A LESSON,
JIM, AND THE LESSON WAS THAT
ABORTION HAS TO BE SAFE,
AFFORDABLE, LEGAL AND AVAILABLE
TO EVERYONE.
THAT IS WHY I SUPPORT ROE V.
WADE, THAT IS WHY I SUPPORTED
NORMA McCORVY WHEN SHE WAS THE
JANE DOE OF ROE V. WADE.
AFTER IT BECAME UNCONSTITUTIONAL
FOR STATES TO CRIMINALIZE
ABORTION, I HAVE BEEN
PASSIONATELY IN SUPPORT OF LEGAL
ABORTION EVER SINCE 1973.
>> SO IT'S NOT JUST A
THEORETICAL DISCUSSION,
OBVIOUSLY.
LET ME MOVE TO THIS.
>> AND THAT'S IMPORTANT IF YOU
SAY THAT, BECAUSE THIS LAW IS
DANGEROUS.
IT'S NOT JUST EXTREME.
IT'S DANGEROUS TO THE SAFETY, TO
THE HEALTH, TO THE WELFARE OF
THESE VULNERABLE WOMEN IN TEXAS,
AND THERE IS A TREND.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE JUST TEXAS,
IT'S GOING TO BE OTHER STATES AS
WELL, MORE THAN 20 STATES NOW
HAVE VERY RESTRICTIVE ABORTION
LAWS, AND WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO
FIGHT AGAINST IT.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO DO.
>> YEAH, AND I WANTED TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE PART THAT IS REALLY
SENDING CHILLS DOWN THE SPINES
OF A LOT OF PEOPLE AROUND THIS
COUNTRY.
IT'S THE PART OF THE TEXAS LAW
THAT ALLOWS CITIZENS TO SUE
ANYONE WHO ASSISTS SOMEBODY
GETTING AN ABORTION.
IN FACT, A SITE THAT WAS
SOLICITING ANONYMOUS TIPS WAS
SHUT DOWN BY ITS WEB HOSTING
COMPANY.
JUSTICE SONIA SOTOMAYOR SAID IT
MADE THEM LOOK LIKE BOUNTY
HUNTERS.
SOME ARE SAYING THAT IS THE
PROVISION OF THE LAW THAT IS
GOING TO END UP HAVING IT TAKEN
OUT AT SOME POINT BY THE SUPREME
COURT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, AND JUSTICE SONIA
SOTOMAYOR, WHO IS ANOTHER ONE OF
MY HEROES, IN ADDITION TO THE
LATE JUSTICE RUTH BADER
GINSBURG, CALLED IT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
AND IT IS UNIQUE.
REPORTEDLY THIS BAN ON ABORTION
IS UNUSUAL AND WAS SUGGESTED BY
A LAW CLERK TO FORMER AND LATE
JUSTICE SCALIA, WHOM WE KNOW WAS
VERY EXTREME AND ANTI-CHOICE.
SO THERE'S GOING TO BE A LOT OF
LITIGATION ABOUT IT.
THERE WAS A TEMPORARY INJUNCTION
ISSUED IN A LAWSUIT YESTERDAY
THAT PLANNED PARENT HOOD BROUGHT
AGAINST RIGHT TO LIFE IN TEXAS,
BUT THAT'S A VERY NARROW RULING.
IT'S A TEMPORARY INJUNCTION THAT
WILL LAST TWO WEEKS, AND THEN
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
BUT THE IDEA THAT ANY STRANGER
COULD SUE AN UBER DRIVER OR A
LYFT DRIVER OR ANYONE WHO THEY
SAY IS AIDING AND ABETTING A
WOMAN THEY DON'T EVEN KNOW TO
GET AN ABORTION IS -- IT WILL
HAVE A CHILLING EFFECT.
>> WHAT IF THAT WOMAN WAS RAPED?
>> RIGHT.
A MOM WHO DRIVES HER PREGNANT
DAUGHTER TO GET AN ABORTION AND
BRINGS HER HOME COULD ALSO BE
SUED.
OR DAD, YOU KNOW, OR THE YOUNG
WOMAN'S HUSBAND.
THIS IS MORE THAN EXTREME.
IT IS UNUSUAL.
I DO ANTICIPATE AT A CERTAIN
POINT IT'S GOING TO BE DECLARED
UNCONSTITUTIONAL IF, AND ONLY
IF, SOME VOTES CHANGE ON THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
BECAUSE THEY REFUSE TO ACCEPT
THIS CASE.
THEY HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO
THIS WEEK.
IT WAS A 5-4 RULING.
SO THE THREE JUSTICES THAT WERE
APPOINTED BY PRESIDENT TRUMP, IN
OTHER WORDS, THEY WERE
NOMINATED, THEY WERE APPOINTED
BY THE SUBCOMMITTEE, AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE THE SAME ONES WHO
ARE GOING TO GET TO DECIDE THIS
ISSUE WHEN IT FINALLY DOES GET
TO THE UNITED STATES SUPREME
COURT, IF IT DOES.
SO EVERYBODY CAN DO SOMETHING.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A NATIONAL
PROTEST DAY ON OCTOBER 2nd ON
THIS LAW.
EVERYBODY NEEDS TO GO TO THE
STREETS, EVERYBODY NEEDS TO
SUPPORT SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IN
HER DESIRE AND WORK TO PASS THE
WOMEN'S HEALTH CARE PROTECTION
ACT.
THERE IS QUITE A BIT THAT WE CAN
ALL DO.
WE'RE GLAD THAT UBER AND LYFT
DECIDED THEY'RE GOING TO PAY THE
LEGAL FEES IF THEIR DRIVERS ARE
SUED FOR TAKING WOMEN TO
ABORTIONS.
A LOT OF OTHER BIG COMPANIES AND
CORPORATIONS STEPPING UP TO THE
PLATE, AND THEY'RE GOING TO HELP
TO PROVIDE FUNDS ALSO TO
TRANSPORT SOME OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO OTHER STATES TO GET
AN ABORTION.
WHY SHOULD ANY WOMAN HAVE TO
LEAVE HOME AND HER OWN STATE IN
ORDER TO GO ELSEWHERE TO GET AN
ABORTION?
WHY DO WE HAVE TO HAVE AN
UNDERGROUND ABORTION FOR THESE
POOR WOMEN, WOMEN WHO ARE RAPED,
WOMEN OF COLOR?
MOST WOMEN OF AFFLUENCE WILL
HAVE THE MONEY TO GO ELSEWHERE,
BUT THAT'S NOT EVERY WOMAN.
WE CANNOT EXPECT THEM TO CARRY
THAT BABY AND DELIVER WHEN WE
KNOW IT'S NOT THEIR DESIRE TO DO
SO.
>> THIS WILL BE CONTINUING IN
MANY WEEKS AHEAD, BUT THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR PERSONAL STORY
ON THIS, BECAUSE